hakim est chauffeur de taxi depuis près
de 23 ans avec des milliers de
kilomètres à son actif le chauffeur
connaît paris par coeur mais la
situation actuelle est une première pour
lui les ruelles sont vraiment vide j'ai
jamais vu paris comme ça et même
proche banlieue aussi ça fait un peu
bizarre on dirait un dimanche tous les
jours une semaine après le début du
confinement
hakim a vu ses journées drastiquement
changé fini les trajets dans tous les
sens
le chauffeur passe plus de temps à
attendre plutôt que sur la route des
bonnes journées on va dire moi
personnellement je parle surtout pour
moi
quelle n 17
le client mais bon après là on est à 3 4
mais bon je vais pas jusqu'au bout à un
moment on est désespéré je veux dire je
rentre un jeu sort comme ça en ce moment
si j'arrive à faire cinq six clients
c'est déjà une situation qui a de
grandes conséquences sur la vie d'hakim
moins de clients c'est moins de revenus
des circonstances alarmante pour le
chauffeur de taxi qui continuent de
travailler malgré tout s'il ne s'alarme
pas encore hakim confesse qu'il vit une
période plus que compliquée chiffre
d'affaires j'ai même pas envie d'en
parler parce que c'est
il n'y a pas de chiffre d'affaires je
parle pour moi après je sais pas mais
bon je crois qu'on est tous touchés le
chiffre d'affaires vraiment on est je
sais pas moi je suis même pas je crois
que ceux à même pas 20 %
un constat partagé par ses collègues qui
ont de plus en plus de mal à tenir le
coup dramatique exceptionnelle du jamais
vu
c'est pratiquement 70 80 % de chiffre
d'affaires en moins c'est simple on fait
pas 20% de chiffre
ces violences ont mis sur le
découragement des collègues en espérant
avoir plus de courses mais ça fait plus
d'une semaine que qu'on est en
confinement et je me fais violence en
sortant tous les jours et ça changera
rien on est à l'arrêt on en plus de deux
heures sans faire sans faire un client
ont fait une course à 7,8 euros pour
pour traverser un arrondissement s'est
jamais vu ça trente ans de métier j'ai
jamais vu ça
le principal problème reste les charges
si les revenus baissent les charges
elles restent les mêmes si hakim peut
encore se payer l'essence et ses courses
le reste devient compliqué et il espère
un petit geste de soutien pour le moment
c'est que deux semaines on essaie de
résister mais après s'il ya problème
[Musique]
on essaiera j'essaierai de trouver une
solution
les charges bon et comme tout le monde
et je crois j'espère qu'il y aura une
petite souplesse qui au mois qui nous
repousse de trois mois en attendant que
ça passe
malgré toutes ces contraintes
hakim décide de continuer à travailler
en soutien à ceux qui doivent sortir
mais après une semaine de confinement
les difficultés du chauffeur de taxi ne
sont pas près de disparaître
d'autant plus si la période est amené à
être prolongé